the ragnerok marked a series of events
that would lead to the end of the world
in Norse mythology much like the story
of creation a new world would be born in
the wake of its destruction
there were many signs that would signal
the ragnaroks arrival the first sign was
the death of the beloved god baal deer
who was slain by loki soon after there
would be a continuous winter that would
last over a year and finally there were
three roosters the first of which would
warn the Giants that the ragnerok had
begun the second would warn the dead and
the third would warn the gods of their
imminent doom loki and Fenrir who had
previously been banished managed to
break free from the imprisonment and
they sided with the frost and fire
Giants led by cert they were also joined
by hel and her army of dishonorable
Undead they set sail on the ship made
from the nails of dead men as they
prepared for their battle against the
gods when the god higham de blew his
horn the Honorable in Valhalla and Falk
venire were able to return from the dead
and aid the gods the giant serpent known
as your meg and rose from the sea and
after a fierce battle Thor would
eventually slay the serpent Thor would
later succumb to death after suffering
multiple poisonous wounds in his battle
against the yawning end Odin rode into
battle on his eight-legged steed but he
would eventually be slain and devoured
by Fenrir Fenrir would later be defeated
by one of Owens of vengeance sons vida
one of the few survivors of the Ragnarok
the children of Fenris skal and hearty
devoured the Sun and the moon plunging
the world into darkness the dragon
nidhogg flew over the battle devouring
the dead as he tried to satisfy his
never-ending hunger Heimdall did not
hesitate when given the chance to kill
his bitter rival Loki and the two took
each other's lives in battle the goddess
Freyja would be killed by the fire
giants earth who set the buyer for us
than the nine worlds on fire as he
watched the world begin to sink into the
boiling sea when the vast majority of
gods and Giants had slain each other the
new world began to rise from the water
before the Ragnarok a man and woman took
shelter in the walled tree Yggdrasil
when the battle was over they would
emerge and repopulate the earth again
there were several gods who survived the
Ragnarok Odin's sons Vita and volley
were among them and Thor's hammer was
passed down to his sons Modi'in Magni
the surviving gods took two-eyed of all
as it remained largely untouched and
they made it their new home
the Giants or Ragnarok is their
opportunity for revenge as their brother
Emil was slain by the gods in order for
the world to be formed the humans are
collateral damage in the war between
gods and Giants and despite the chaotic
destruction a new world was born if
you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained